[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the lobby
game swaps weekly live show here in San
Francisco California every Wednesday
11:00 a.m. Pacific I'm Mike McCarty here
with Pete Brown as usual hello
what is this proper stance I'm just a
nose Rob why are you guys doing this
that's Rob Handler e hi and callyblackie
what are you doing nothing nothing
you're already rustling me yeah so we
usually do a giveaway at the beginning
the show but we don't have one this week
mainly because Shiva who measures our
Twitter is out and I have no idea how to
set those up no I'm just kidding not
really but yeah we don't have a giveaway
today but we will get back on that as
usual next week is our first show since
e3 we did a live show for those of you
who were able to stop by that was fun
I'm sure you know for those who were
able to watch it still fun as usual yeah
it was fun would you guys think of e3
overall Callie would you think of it
you've done a few e3 s before right this
is my favorite to work probably one of
the more like mellow shows as far as
like my excitement for things that I've
said I've done but I really liked the
work that I did and so yeah I was really
satisfied with the with e3 overall
rather about you um he was weird I had
like a different role this time I was
kind of doing a little more of the back
end a little bit of delegation stuff but
for the most part I know so I was
surprised how not tired I was by the end
compared the other years mm-hmm
I don't know maybe that's just me being
an adult like going to bed reasonably
adults are very flexible because I feel
like we all worked hard we played even
harder and like no one got hung over
well I was I didn't get a single
hangover that's amazing I think I was
actually sick the entire week I didn't
get days but anyway yeah so news items
before I might get back to e3 with a
couple things Xbox one X and games that
were missing from e3 then we're also
gonna be talking about Super Nintendo
classic what games are confirmed and
missing and our thoughts on that and
just overall like what other games we
have coming in the summer before the
holiday season starts but news items
Zelda DLC coming off Friday so Rob will
get enough
on all weekend st. Pete man Kali and
everyone think about canceling this
wedding going to you're gonna cancel the
wedding just message everybody involved
so yeah for those who don't know will
rob you probably know more than I do
it's master trials that's what we're
watching here and the core rock mass but
so to initiate the master trials have to
return the mask or to the pedestal and
then is that what happens and then so
the master trials like that wave or you
start off with nothing then you have to
go through waves of enemies and whatnot
reminds me of like Tron you know no but
[Music]
going into the trial this is a nice
orange so what do you do in master mode
it's like it's wave based kind of it's
got like the Cave of trials if that's
what it was called in Twilight Princess
when you go to the Gerudo desert if you
played that yeah there's a lot there's
hero's path which traces your movement
throughout the map of the game it's sort
of like the same concept as even tied at
random that you're going in without
everything you've gathered throughout
the game it's just cool which a lot of
us talked about that being one of our
favorite parts of breadth of the wild
when we ran through it the first time
yeah cool
I think and the Nintendo representative
who was there on the stage I couldn't
answer this I didn't look it up but I
can't remember if an even tide I know
you lose your armor and your weapons
but do you lose like all of your
supplies and and food okay you guys
pronouncing it differently than I'm used
to I call it event ID well because it
evens the tide as I certainly thank God
I guess so I mean that I got to tease
could be very wrong it could be event I
don't know anyways but yeah you got on
track you start off with a freaking
branch and you're going up against these
guys and some Under Armour shorts yokas
what's interesting is I think in this
footage you'll see in this footage
you'll see the health regen of these
guys so like no longer can you I don't
know do those moves were like you're
just running away dropping bombs like
you have to like isolate an individual
enemy and just work him that's
interesting that that's interesting that
they actually work
work them he's got to work them
interesting that they actually put you
into this scenario where you can first
approach with stealth I thought it was
just like combat throughout so it's a
mixture different things so the I think
we only got two and they're calling
these floors
so it was like floor four or four four
three is what we got to which is again
there's there's 45 floors levels
wherever you go column but we just saw
kind of combat stuff supposedly some of
these will have puzzles like almost like
pulling on like the shrines you do
physics-based puzzles and then I don't
know he didn't you know again the rep
didn't confirm this but my my suspicion
is that the last floor is gonna be like
three gold Lionel's and a gold Lionel
will be that will be the ultimate enemy
of the game I got a better idea what if
the last few floors are the various
incarnations of Ganon from different
Zelda games oh yeah yeah that'd be cool
though you know I think like that
happening who knows it's unlikely Mike
but goddammit a guy can dream you're far
more positive today that I'm used to
it's throwing me on snapchat I'm feeling
it yeah people just discovered Face Swap
on snapchat today what you know about
apps
all right also if you are Diablo 3 fan
how many years after released 5 the
necromancer pack is out now it's a new
character class returning from Diablo 2
with some tweaks it's $15 use want to
get the necromancer and then you can
also get the eternal Edition which take
could correct me if I'm wrong we're
pretty sure it's just the ultimate evil
plus the necromancer so anything that's
ever released with the game both on PC
ps4 Xbox one should be live if you want
to play that if you hadn't already
started I was gonna last night but I
played X come to and I was awake until
3:00 a.m. playing that I'm also next
machina we have a review that went up
last week we can talk about this game I
don't think we talked about it too
extensively on the lobby we definitely
didn't play too extensively in the lobby
at e3 because it came out right after
next not next machina review ate a
freelancer who did this Jason Day Perl
which is the correct pronunciation of
his name he gave it a 9 out of 10
skin fun
did you all play it Rob you played a
fair amount of it yeah I totally did I
really like this game it's real real
tough from a Swedish developer house
mark if you know from resogun the ps4
launch title which is kind of a long
title yes I also they have matter fall
coming out which apparently is our take
on the Shadow Complex kind of
Metroidvania ish game that'll be out
actually kind of soon like August if I'm
not mistaken maybe September but yeah
this game is a twin-stick shooter very
very hard in some parts kind of to
punishing in my opinion but it I had a
lot of fun with it it can be like Peter
you had said this I didn't really like
put together until I experienced it
myself which is in this game you know
you do like the arcade feature which is
you know you have to play all the five
worlds in order all at once oh there's
no auto-saves it's an arcade basically
an hour long yeah roughly but the the
like the best part or what you are
striving for is to quickly get like max
of upgrades as far as like all the
abilities like wider spread on your gun
[ __ ] this part a triple this merge stuff
a triple - once you get all that you're
rockin and you you just feel like you're
on top of the world but it's so intense
because once you lose that that triple -
especially uh-huh you have the hardest
time recovering because you're just you
just you know back to like square one
again the triple - is so key because
you're you know you're consistently able
to like avoid objects but when you have
one oh my god
anyways it's just when you fall you fall
hard is what I'm getting at and you just
I don't know
it's it's really tough but it enjoyable
in that respect of just the intensity
that and the focus that's required
I really like this game yeah it's super
fun it's it's interesting to see how
housemarque has kind of evolved what
they did with resogun I mean they
haven't really I mean have they really
say anything before resogun Super
Stardust superstars never played that is
if anything more of an evolution of that
style of gameplay but it's a direct
homage to Robotron 2084 and smash
mother-effing TV which i don't know if
any of you guys ever wanted what was i
would USA resogun was
kind of continuation of what's a call to
defend area the others bosses can get
pretty tough this one wasn't the hardest
one but yeah it seems like you can pick
us up on PlayStation Network right now
and we give another 10 NPC and the
entire soundtrack is on Spotify oh it's
so good yeah we we had to turn the music
down for capturing because it was so
loud music and it's such a different
game without the soundtrack because
escalate when you go from stated stage
you were showing us one time at one
point when it becomes a boss fight in
the actual soundtrack kind of changes
yeah all the boss battles have a
different soundtrack and just that that
transition is just every time it happens
I just like subconsciously I'm like
bobbing my head even though it's gonna
be a hell of a fight I
yeah this game is real fun yeah you
should play this it's very good what
that this game looks someone said they
wish that follow Fantasy 6 instead of
Final Fantasy 3 was in the SNES classic
but it's probably like one of my jokes I
would assume but anyway we are kind of
you know farther away from e3 now we saw
you know Microsoft announced the pricing
release date of the Xbox one X now so I
wanted to now that hits time it's had
time to kind of you know like percolate
I want to get your thoughts on this Pete
you think $500 is a good price I think
it's a fair price I'd it's it's enough
to make me think twice about actually
buying an Xbox 1x $400 would have been
great but yeah 500 I don't know I can't
do that if I had a 4k TV and I was like
itching for something to like really
show it off maybe I'd go for it but yeah
so that'll be and I think but the one
thing that a lot of people notice was
despite the fact that Microsoft showed
42 games at the press conference not not
many of them were
Xbox exclusives you know like we saw a
lot of crackdown or no like not a lot
but we saw a little bit of crackdown 3
which I think was one of the bigger
titles we were waiting to see from the
show who saw that they showed it at the
press conference game play mm-hmm a
little bit not a lot
it was pretty brief I don't blame you
for forgetting it because it was very
brief compared to what we thought I just
remember that Terry Crews trailer yeah
yeah yeah that was the Microsoft
conference yeah oh yeah we will have
more coming out for that game soon just
played a little bit of it the other day
it looks fun I mean I it looks gorgeous
I'm not super into dragon ball at all
but I see the appeal of the game I saw
it like people on YouTube are comparing
the animations in that game to the
actual anime and it looks pretty
faithful it looks a lot like the
animation in Super so if you don't like
the animations super like can take that
into account but it's it's cool I was
thinking I mean she's going back to Xbox
one X I like haven't had no desire to
get a 4k TV number one because that's
expensive and I'll place put it but I
like I'm not really I don't really care
about that so much when I'm playing
games um but I would really like to see
Dragon Ball and like the highest
fidelity possible is so pretty yes by
the developers of guilty gear same kind
of art style hmm it looks really good
especially when you're using like the
supers or whatever level three and five
or whatever I don't know I heard Eric
hey screaming a bunch of things and
they're playing yeah they were saying
all these complicated terms and I was
just like this isn't canon so I was
focused on other things yeah yeah like
this stuff is so cool it looks so good I
have a question this is gonna probably
come off pretty dumb cuz I'm not very
smart he get into it on fighting games
but like the frame rate of these
animations is that something that can
collect contradict like I don't know
predicting moves for like a fighting
game but like the frame rate of these
animations is that people people get
super into like the frame counts and
whatnot of different moves
yeah and predictively I'm saying but
there's nothing distinct about this game
necessarily compared to other fighting
games that I can that is like readily
apparent you know yeah are you talk
about this game in particular yes I am
yeah I don't know I don't see anything
that seems out of the ordinary if
anything I will say that this game does
a really good job of capturing the the
pacing that makes Dragon Ball fights so
exciting now there's a lot of pacing
issues in the anime where the people
just stand around charging up and like
and this that and the other but this
just hits those moments at a really
action-packed whereas a lot of Dragon
Ball Z fighting games they will
sacrifice depth to make that happen or
if they try to be a deep 2d fighter like
some of the older games for like the
Saturn and Super Nintendo just stand
around charging a lot it was boring this
looks like the most faithful and
exciting Dragon Ball Z fighting game
yeah and then so they show this the
Microsoft press conference and like I
was saying they showed a little bit of
crackdown 3 and then they showed a bunch
of other games in terms of exclusives
there's not many and that was the worry
going into the show yeah but especially
considering they don't they didn't even
show off their like their flagship
franchise halo 6 wut you know is coming
and then of course Gears of War 5 whole
bench will eventually roll around from
the coalition but I mean there was Ori
and the whispering willows I might be
butchering that it was just like a
double W but I'm really excited for that
it's not like a console seller for me
despite the fact that I love it or in
the blind forest
I don't know Callie do you think you'll
be interested in getting an Xbox one X
when it releases no I my favorite thing
about my xbox is the controller I have
an elite controller and that is why I
still play games on xbox aside like
shooters yeah I play a lot of shooters
on xbox primarily and to play with
that's where like people I play shooters
with play but I I don't need to upgrade
I don't need to spend five hundred
dollars to get that same experience so
that's I'm not looking for the you know
highest fidelity like top the line
experience with my xbox so it's just not
that important to me I'm not playing at
a high level I don't need that it
becomes a problem when you want to
upgrade when you know like they can't
you know use the 60 frames at a game
like destiny cuz then it would kind of
imbalance the Xbox one X and Xbox 1 s
players right alright so that kind of
becomes a problem they showed off Metro
Exodus at the show as well that game
looks really good apparently I was
actually an engine and everything which
doesn't surprise me because I just
played Metro
Last Light Redux recently and those
games are really gorgeous still even
though there's despite the fact that
2033 came out 2010 last light was 2013
they look really good updated but yeah I
do I am curious on Twitter we actually
had a question about this from Jeremy's
all he was saying do you still think
it's worth buying an Xbox one x given
the earth sorry an Xbox one vanilla
given the announcement of the X what
would you do that at this point
it's an Xbox 1s or just regular Xbox one
Pete I guess it depends on why you want
to buy an Xbox in the first place yeah
yeah if you don't have one by now you
know is there any incentive or is there
any point and not just going you know
exporting for the X yeah it depends what
you want you must really want those
Microsoft exclusives or want to just get
the best performing console you can at
the same time you have to imagine like
anybody who really will likes Halo or
Gears war would have one by now right
yeah like if you were all about the Xbox
games you would probably have gotten it
sooner I just yeah I'm not really seeing
the the reasoning and that part of that
is that I don't care about 4k but also
what am I going to play on it anyway
mm-hmm and like in terms of going from
the Xbox 1s or Xbox one to the Xbox one
X my god that's a mouthful I don't like
the name Xbox one X what do you think
the name actually really quick I like it
I think it's fine I don't think they
mean what are their options right
there's no really good option for the
Scorpio just keep Scorpio that's not a
brand name you slap on a console well
it's releasing when is in is releasing
under the sign of the Scorpio zodiac
that was my prediction number before
they announced the release date I was
like it's gonna be between what is
October September 23rd and no no October
I don't know anyway that doesn't matter
sit down Canyon it's coming out like if
you are a Scorpio you're born in this
yes I don't know I I think the ultimate
thing for me is yeah you definitely have
a lot of pros and cons to weigh but one
of the biggest is like all right what
what are my friends on like I don't have
any friends who are like who are like
you know 3:16 hell yeah but like I just
I can't I don't want to buy something
than just be alone and isolated right
like I mean I I don't know there's not
enough reasoning but like you know come
next year is what I'm looking at like
again yeah halo like if halo was coming
out this year maybe
like consider but I don't know make the
jokes there's this not enough arrow
mosques on in a twitch at also mentioned
cuphead finally has a release date after
they've taken really long which is
understandable considering it's all hand
animated kind of like Oh an old-school
Disney cartoon game looks great it's not
just a boss run now like it used to be
kind of you're going through this small
overworld going from boss - boss it's
really hard but now it actually looks
like there's a general structure leading
from boss the boss
it's like Zelda I'm excited for it but
it's not gonna sell an Xbox one is
breeze past that for a second
Pete and Zelda references what other
games like Zelda see Dragon Ball Z Gerda
mana that's a joke that happened before
the show started rob was so then he was
saying this just looks like Zelda it's a
fair point of comparison Jesus at which
point I said no it doesn't and then he
drew this photo of you can't probably
see it from that it's link throwing up
on me and he misspelled my last name for
those who Mar Hardy for those of you
listening on iTunes right now it's
essentially just this massive ugly link
with cross-eyes throwing up on me and
I'm and you very ugly in this photo
cool but any last thoughts of Xbox 1x
you guys okay to clarify I do want one I
did actually want pretty badly just I
want a reason to play on my xbox more I
think it was like Rob what you were
saying most of my friends playing
PlayStation that's just like the one I
you know like that's honestly that's the
input source that my TV's on I turn it
on a lot of times so I'll just be like
it's my default that's a good point like
I actually just recently like finally
upgraded my own TV and I did the whole
4k HDR so like that is enticing as hell
like yeah but what am i watching honest
my streaming 4k like cop had a look
Doven oh yeah it could be a cool
entertainment box down the road but I
think it's everyone should just kind of
wait it doesn't feel like a new
generation of console and that's the
asking price that they put on it is what
you would charge for a new console so
they're charging 400 IB
I mean right that's still pretty close
to like you know a new gen yeah but
still 500 is like just pushing it just
past that line enough where it's like
well what yeah
we've said it what are we getting out of
it hard to say I would like them to
spend more time on the UI yeah fixed
stupid operating seriously it was just
what isn't most of it just meant to
reflect Windows 10 most ads but the
first thing you see the top promo slot
is that it's it's the store like watched
a movie on that and then tried to get
back to the dashboard and been like I
don't know how I feel like an old person
using my xbox I don't know how it works
clearly you press lb and X at the same
time and then what about your ceiling
and pray to God and it should appear
really ironic that I'm wearing an Xbox
t-shirt right yeah it's gotten better
yeah I think I use my xbox more than
most people do like I actually yeah yeah
yeah I would rather they spend more more
time and put a little more attention
into some like quality of life things
and like UX stuff mm-hmm then I mean
obviously I'm a weird case but no no
yeah I'm I I mean I like you were saying
you like the controller more which for
like shooters becomes a big deal in a
Playstation one I do like the Xbox one
controller yeah that's about it that's
like I say I don't know it's comfortable
for me seriously my elite controller was
like the best purchase I love yeah how
much of those now 820 yeah 150 when he
came out yeah but anyway yeah I guess
like those the last time we'll talk
about Xbox 1x for a little bit if you
want to go on a GameSpot Jimmy our tech
editor he just did an evolution of Xbox
console kind of gallery thing he's gonna
check that out but yeah anyway before we
move on from e3 before we've you know
like kind of that runs dry I want to
talk about games that we personally
we're missing I know there's a bunch
obviously like we mentioned halo 6
already it's kind of weird it's not
weird I mean like they said we know it's
coming maybe they just wanted to take
the time to show off a broader range of
game because they really do there's 42
and they rifled through them after doing
like 10 minutes with the xbox 1x which
which was a smart move I think they
showed it off they got like all the
burning questions out of the way price
release date kind of like last minute
specs that we might not have known about
but I think we knew a lot of them
they went into the games I was initially
a little bummed today in show hello but
then again I I'm so kind of over getting
hyped and spending a whole year getting
hyped for a game like if it wasn't come
if you know talked about this year I I'm
just not interested well that was the
strength of Bethesda's conference too
cuz like everything they talked about
was coming out this year which is like
you have license to get excited about
that um I mean I'm sort of in your camp
but that like I I would have been super
stoked to say hello I love halo so much
I thought Microsoft's conference was
strong overall but that would have
really knocked it out of the park for me
I like Halo 5 more yeah I don't like the
story but I like the level design things
actually yeah but yeah and then
obviously like yours were Forge released
last year they didn't show much of 5 off
from the coalition being there another
one of their flagship series but yeah
ODA been nice to see that the Last of Us
part 2 was also missing and Naughty Dog
after we're just saying it was because
they wanted to keep attention on
Uncharted the Lost Legacy yeah which
actually if I saw it last with part 2
that might actually a me up a little
more for uncharted despite the fact that
totally they was seemed very different
obviously with Chloe Fraser and Nadine
Ross from uncharted Fame they're going I
mean done cards always been a little
more you know light-hearted then they
went with the last of us especially
judging by this trailer to see how
Elly's changed she's got a tattoo now so
you know she's killed people yeah you
know but they didn't show off anything
they showed this teaser at PSX last year
and then since then we haven't really
seen much obviously you know like we
wonder how far it's in development but
this looks really good but Joel and
Ellie are both coming back apparently
they were mo capping a pig so I'm pretty
stuff what yeah that was in the news
yesterday they were mo capping a pig and
pigs are adorable so to use in the game
or just for fun no just for shits and
giggles I think Ellie is a phenomenal
character and I loved the original yeah
um and so I mean Sony's commerce was so
underwhelming ii mean this is something
that the
a lot of cared about personally during
that conference so this would have
helped a lot yeah so I was about where
we didn't see that Pete you also brought
up death stranding yesterday yeah yeah
not totally surprising Kojima said that
he wasn't gonna bring it to the show
there was some like thing he wore like a
t-shirt that had the spider web on it
that yeah it's got something to do with
the game ostensibly but who knows yeah
any there's so much like what was he
saying that he actually came to shop for
he tweeted that thing and obviously that
Kojima there's always a reason for
everything he does according to some
people I would happen to disagree with
that but he tweeted what was it like a
cobweb or spiderweb or something yeah oh
it's hearted bridges yeah just utter
genius no one's claiming it's genius you
fool no I mean it probably means
something I mean he's talked about how
death stranding is a game that features
like worlds that are connected but like
in ways that are untraditional and if
you look at a spiderweb like yeah you
know there's all these different means
of things that are connected so I don't
know who knows mm-hmm we're talking
about it early do we have any idea what
this game is yet like I think it's a
match-three puzzle game make sense Robin
kind of play into those quick p-47s the
nice Thunderbolts I I'm interested to
see what axes to come to this and when
we'll see it next I don't know would it
be like a PSX thing or do you think
they'd just do something on their own at
Kojima or like just they won't do
anything on their own no I mean Sony's
publishing this right Sony's gonna
leverage it as one of their trailers we
did get a nice Geoff Keeley Kojima
picture from e3 so I am says that
bromance that's how you love it so much
I live for it Geoff Keeley's probably
pretty jealous of the romance between
Kojima and Mads Mikkelsen no can we talk
about how Kojima like tweets the most
like I want someone to tweet about me
the way he talks about I guess somebody
I know I shouldn't actually I'm gonna
spider was but you know yeah he's always
like oh look at how beautiful that is
I'm like you and your hammer move boys I
love it I think it's good you must like
a fan of these people and so he gets to
meet them and he's freaking out the way
some fans would say I adore it
it brings light to my life we also you
Kelly you mentioned the Fez of the
conference the strength was that they
didn't go past holiday 2017 which I
thought was smart I mean I mean it would
have been nice to see something so I
wrote down Elder Scrolls games six six
or fallouts been off for maybe obsidian
that we thought might have been coming
like project Louisiana and all those
rumors about a new orleans-based kind of
New Vegas ish spin-off we didn't see
anything like that yeah i am i like
bethesda games and i thought you know
it's it's strong to target what's you
know immediate I'm very excited for
Wolfenstein but it would be nice to have
like one thing that was just out of
reach to get excited about and that
would have been for me Elder Scrolls I
mean they really milk Skyrim right so
it's like obviously I'm very excited to
play Skyrim on like two new platforms or
whatever because I'm a nerd about it
it's in a different reality yeah just a
platform different dimension get to play
his hobo link yeah oh my god that it
looks like they took Skyrim character
and face swapped it with Lincoln creepy
I would have loved because we know Elder
Scrolls 6 is happening I would I want to
know more about it yeah I'm I'm actually
really excited to put to try out fallout
4 and Skyrim in VR and Doom VR looks
very odd because it seems like the
antithesis of doom you're like
teleporting and then shooting and then
doom is always just about forward
movement doom like playing doom the
first time around like not in VR I was
like doing you know it's a it's a kill
rooms so you're like moving around in
circles and kind of looking I feel like
I would get sick immediately yeah so
like I think the teleportation thing is
to fix that but I don't know how that
makes it like doom teleporting is
generally where I always get the motion
sickness anytime really yeah it's when
I'm like being warped to a different
area right and then it's a you just are
readjusting where where my location is
so it's like I don't know that can
definitely throw me off so that scares
me as well I'm curious to try this out
just to see those doom weapons in VR and
everything
they showed you kind of using the the
minigun whatnot but I actually just want
to try it out because this seems a
little more I feel like I could play
through this whereas fallout 4 in Skyrim
I'm gonna try out and probably won't get
too far into you know in the grand
scheme of things well those are games I
would spend you know over a hundred
hours in and I just can't do that in VR
I mean that would take me two years to
do whereas when I first got Skyrim I
think I put in sixty hours in a week or
something like that yeah uh I'm curious
to see how this turns out but yeah but
that's actually kind of focused a lot on
VR between fall-off for Skyrim mm-hmm
doom eye but like again you said it
would have been nice to see them to you
something but again that doesn't seem to
be their thing anymore they like fallout
for three months before it came out when
they finally officially showed it off
editor conference last year yeah I mean
come on the two years ago sorry they
totally surprised us yeah with people
with into in Wolfenstein yeah yeah it's
really hard to say like yeah yeah cuz
evil than two is Friday the 13th October
13th and then October 27th which we keep
talking about this but that day is
stacked it's Sanskrit origins SuperMario
Odyssey and Wolfenstein - the new
Colossus so I'm already - I don't know
what I'm gonna play first I figured it
out what I'm I wasn't much you know
wasn't a hard decision I want to do
Wolfenstein - Super Mario Assassin's
Creed eventually get to Assassin's Creed
that's not that day one thing for me
although I am really excited for that
game which I haven't been for an
assassin's creed's since I don't know
before Sanskrit 3 maybe but yeah I'm
really excited for that day but October
in general is pretty stacked cuz shadow
4 comes out between evil within 2 and
all those games I'm sure I'm missing a
couple titles but October is probably
the month and then like a week after
those games it's called 2d World War 2
and then a little bit after that's
Battlefront - I don't know it's a
holiday season it's always gonna be
packed but October 27 specifically so
he's pretty crazy other games that we
missed are we surprised that we didn't
see cyberpunk from but did you miss it I
do want to know more about that game
like I I we see the same you know with
the Android the sexy Android girl or
whatever I want to that was Detroit
you're mixing them up
cyberpunk 2077 is one of the most
anticipated games yeah out there right
now it's game everyone wants to know
about like no one has any like concerns
about like oh maybe they're gonna botch
it like No The Witcher 3 was amazing CD
Projekt RED is there on the ball
hopefully it's gonna really get like the
moment they share this off it's going to
be a huge deal like when we finally get
to see gameplay it's gonna be a big big
deal and like you were saying Rob it's
getting tired now they'd like to wait
years for something so I think once we
finally get to see this game in action
it'll probably be probably years from
now but when the game is going to be
coming out in a matter of months not
years yeah it's interesting I think the
big question on my mind is what they're
actually gonna do with this property
because they the witcher wasn't
established you know like canon and then
they took that and made it into this you
know like the evolution of the winter
series super interesting the first
whitter was so different than the third
one they went just massive open world
RPG with a third game obviously but I'm
curious to see what they'll do with
cyberpunk I would assume they would go
in the same vein of The Witcher but who
knows what they actually will end up
doing there better not be horses that's
all I'm saying well interesting the one
of the most enticing things I heard was
that they were hiring this is like a
year ago I feel like they were they were
trying to hire a developer that would
specialize in like ship I don't know how
it was to say it but like like she's
like ammount free like I'd like it
basically the replacement of roche being
your ship
someone specialized in that and I think
that is freaking cool I mean that just
kind of solidifies like the the open
world idea of like flying around in
these cities yeah I just yeah this game
god what does this game look like yeah
not just not surprised that it was
omitted from e3 on CD projects part they
were still pushing uh-oh
quint right and they had that that leak
where they kind of like they said like
we're not going to bend to their like
ransom basically or someone was like oh
pay us and we won't oh yeah they're like
we don't negotiate yeah well they really
just so you know it's really early on
I'm like oh we're not hearing about this
game for a long time so also people who
are blackmailing people for that like
can just no I almost just got really mad
for a second but seriously like you're
worse than the Mass Effect 3 people Star
Wars of the
Cyril star wars that we've been kind of
waiting to hear it's not again it's not
surprising that we didn't see Amy Hennig
Star Wars the one that she's been
working on with visceral and I don't
think it's surprising because I think
they smartly you know they focused on
battlefront too although you know it
would have been it would have been I
think a good time to drum up excitement
for this more narrative focus Star Wars
especially considering you know episode
eights not that far away anymore in the
grand scheme of things I'm coming out
December so a battlefront 2 is November
but obviously like visceral has been
working on a narrative ish it ei was I
mean it's the smart move to be like from
a business standpoint like alright just
you know if you're gonna buy one Star
Wars game like that's what we want to
deliver this right yeah you don't want
cannibalize your own sales by splitting
people's attention between two different
Star Wars things right anything people
would just buy both those games anyway a
lot of people would like a lot of Star
Wars fans but I don't know I feel like
if you want to showcase one thing and it
seems like they're really proud of what
they've done with battlefront 2 mm-hmm
then you know just like commit fully to
that yeah it's just like going all-in on
one property right like if you're a star
Wars fan this is a must buy right yeah
and obviously they're smart to have the
first order being a playable team in the
game 4 of course the tie-in with the new
movie yeah well they're going back to
the Colonia and they're coming forward
to the yeah the first-order and
resistance whatnot which is exciting
because I'm kind of you know like I'm
looking forward to the fact that that's
more of a shooter now than just a Star
Wars game you know dice knows what
they're doing with multiplayer shooter
so I'm excited to see what happens with
that I yeah so that's is there anything
else I didn't mention that we wanted to
see at e3 that we didn't Shenmue 3 baby
yeah what ways up there Oh rising will
to remake I didn't write down John Luke
sorry if you could bring up the role for
that if you want to yeah I'll get past
it but resin evil to remake I'm actually
really surprised Capcom didn't show it
off I thought it was a good time
considering this is success commercially
and critically for res evil 7 and you
know like they've they've talked a bunch
we know resin able to remake must be you
know close to being done at this point
it's been now it's like it's not like
Final Fantasy 7 like we know it's coming
sometime soon ish I'm surprised I didn't
show more of that
and I'm really eager to see that because
you know the team that's making this is
is not the team that did zero and remake
it's kind of an unproven team when it
comes to the fixed camera classic resin
evil right it's team that worked on
Phoenix Wright games yeah yeah we're
departure no yeah here's resonable -
this is not the remake
obviously this is more this looks older
this is me and Mary Kish playing
Resident Evil you can go watch that on
YouTube right now Peter yorck an evil
fan you can LuAnn sapphire here
yeah you can't read in the subtitles of
how long it took Mary my Knievel fan is
that what you asked no joke
I would like to see resonable to remake
at e3 surprise Capcom didn't show it off
alright another thing I want to talk
about what we're bummed is missing is uh
from the senesce classic terrible segue
Super Nintendo classic announced
officially
yesterday or two days ago two days ago
Monday and it's gonna be how much Pete
hit me $9.99 on September the 29th BAM
I'm 29 for $79.99 I'm more excited for
this and I was for that es classic I've
actually played a lot of these games so
I'll rattle through them actually now
I'm gonna I'm gonna start listing them
off and scream as loud as you can for
the ones you really excited for I'm just
kidding good all right contra 3 the
alien wars yep Donkey Kong Country ooh
earthbound I've never played I'm excited
to play this finally I Final Fantasy II
3/6 I'm looking forward to finally
playing that f-zero mmm kirby superstar
kirby's dream course legend of zelda a
link to the past with that Megaman X
yeah Secret of Mana starfox okay the
only Star Fox 2 tree Fighter 2 turbo
hyper fighting super Castlevania 4 super
ghouls and ghosts yeah Super Mario Kart
super mario RPG legend the seven stars
super mario world super metroid super
punch-out and Yoshi's Island a lot of
good games come into this but there are
a few we are kind of you know a lament
for these games if you will okay well
first of all pit Pete what's pick one on
that list that you're really excited for
[Laughter]
John Luke cut to camera Chrono Trigger I
think that's the one that was mine
awesome I'm bummed that they
Final Fantasy 3 and not Final Fantasy 6
yes chrono triggers mine as well yeah
you stole the words of my mouth I'm
didn't have mad no no I said which one
are you excited for not what are you
missing well she looked a gun whoops I
will get back to crunch ogre what are
you excited for that's on the list
Chandler cut to camera go chrono trigger
[Laughter]
kai pick two sure I won't play Super
Mario World again yeah my god I love
that game Yoshi's Island is better come
No come at me that's that's false that's
that's the soundtrack to your she's
island I also have a lot of a Twitter
questions about the smash classic so
let's get through this ah okay sorry
Star Fox 2 man what is that yeah it's
it's not a great game oh dude yeah
there's been a version that's like that
just a complete leaked online for years
it was stolen from a trade show which is
a great story actually but you never
owned a Super Nintendo right I laughed
it was funny
that's gang wacky yeah Callie what's
your game you're excited for I Super
Mario RPG yeah and I want to replay a
Link to the Past
that's hell yeah one of my top 3 Zelda's
mm-hmm rightly so yeah so good game I'm
very excited for that I'm looking
forward to the fact that I finally have
a like a solid excuse and maybe a more
accessible way to finally play Final
Fantasy 6 mm-hmm and earthbound neither
of which I've ever touched oh I should
have said earth I'm very excited for it
earthbound is good I was like Justin hey
well it's like favorite game right yeah
themed after yes yeah so he probably
likes it a little bit maybe but now we
can move on to Chrono Trigger and other
games were kind of sad or not on that
list
talk about Chrono Trigger and why they
wouldn't include it Pete I don't know
cut to camera monologue talk about
Prometric or why do you like it why you
said it's gone
Chrono Trigger is the intersection of
two of Japanese RPG developments biggest
properties Dragon Quest and Final
Fantasy Nobuo Uematsu and usually horror
both contribute to this game with keep
going this is a fantastic example of
storytelling it has very innovative
combat for the time it was originally
designed to be a so Nintendo PlayStation
CD game was revamped for the cartridge
format which actually ended up
benefiting combat but really this has an
amazing story incredible characters a
fantastic soundtrack and is a perfect
example of the capabilities and
potential that the Super Nintendo
represented shame on you Nintendo for
not putting Chrono Trigger in the Super
Nintendo classic what's your theory on
why they don't have it on the Super
Nintendo classic jean-luc one more time
why don't they have it money politics
religion I don't know pick one pick two
[Laughter]
I can't really about pilot wings yeah
yes just appreciate so good that's a
person he's the guy create a dragon
dragon ball and has forever been the
principal collaborator with Yuji Horii
on Dragon Quest okay helix dragons
apparently he loves things you told me
pilot wings should be on there too pilot
wings was one of the best launch titles
for the Super Nintendo it had a bunch of
different activities it was a really in
technical impressive game as well
because it used this mode 7 thing to
create sort of this you could call it
pseudo 3d it's basically 3d it just
added incredible depth to the world and
had great personality as well like all
these people that are giving you your
licenses they're charming and weird in
their own ways and after a while you
finally get your license and you think
okay I get what this game is about No
then there's a hostage situation then
you have to rescue all these people yeah
like the whole game just takes a huge
left turn you never see coming
I mean look at this right like the fact
that you're skydiving from thousands of
feet up in the air like all this stuff
like that that's super impressive for a
16-bit console don't think for a launch
title that looks more like you're
ascending on a rope ladder you're gonna
fall in a second what if that helped the
sky dope you actually skydive that is a
weird way to do that
that's terrifying I don't want a sky
about actraiser and Sun goes actraiser
is an interesting game Justin hey wold
really likes it a lot it's kind of an
awkward mix up a godson in a platformer
and neither one I don't think has really
developed its like close but how do you
combine those two cuz I don't know
anything about this game it's been a
long time I forget you you sort of you
meet this this baby with wings and you
ask it to make things for you right and
you end yeah and then you end up
fighting monsters of the sword
God Sam / platformer sounds like Peter
Molyneux and Shigeru Miyamoto hooked up
and had a baby because any other Super
Nintendo games you guys aren't there so
hit me with a few our type 3 our - type
3 is that correct
what's that about you are correct sir
our type 3 so there was super r-type
which was a launch like side-scrolling
spaceship shooter and the Super Nintendo
it was good our type 3 just was an
incredible sort of like technical and
artistic evolution of that series and
it's a great game and I don't know why
it's not on there yeah look at this art
seriously for a Super Nintendo game it's
like axiom verge what kind of body parts
are we looking at folks I'll leave it up
to your imagination how many body parts
of that type are we looking at three
that does look really good but yeah it
looks like axiom verge tried to emulate
this kind of yes dope game I mean
there's there's the thing about the
Super Nintendo is that there are so many
good games you could never please
everyone
I don't really grow up I kind of did
grow up on I grew up more on that in
season four but Super Nintendo is
probably my favorite console I would say
as far as you know like the quality of
its library yeah get PlayStation and
like Nintendo DS those of some of the
strongest libraries ever the good thing
about I mean you have a lot of access to
like you can play Chona trigger on other
things like you're not yes yes sort of
yeah I mean like you can get on yes you
know it's like a because it's you know
such a strong library it's been
re-released
so I'm not too bummed about missing
certain games especially I didn't have a
s ness I had a Genesis when I was a kid
and then we got a n64 so I went I ended
up playing a lot of these games after
the fact so I'm just happy to have an
excuse to to play them and like own a
pseudo SNES I mean I feel like that's
that's the idea though which is why
people I think that specifically chrono
triggers want to hear everyone talk
about like there's such a good
representation of all these different
genres on there and you could almost
tell the complete like the important RPG
story of the Super Nintendo if you had
Chrono Trigger on there right I think
that's the most glaring omission yes it
was my first big RPG it's what got me
into the genre yeah I think it that is
probably like the only one that I'm
actually upset isn't there yeah it's
it's super impressive collection
otherwise I do have a bunch of questions
some of the chat was just asking how
many there are total its 21 games 21
games and yeah that will be it's already
sold out in the UK for pre-orders on
Amazon yeah yeah but they've opened up
there's been like a couple of rounds on
Amazon UK so you think it'll be just a
big [ __ ] of trying to buy one
again like it wasn't any use classic
Nintendo said they're gonna be making a
lot more they said in the past they were
surprised by the demand for the NES
classic and so they're doing
substantially more now again for this
but they've also said it's only gonna be
made up until the end of the year based
on their current plans that could change
but interesting and the UK one does look
super different yep the UK Super
Nintendo is just like the Japanese Super
Famicom and by that I mean much better
looking than our ugly Super Nintendo no
I want the the Japanese box specifically
yeah so gorgeous we have our whatever
one yeah and the Japanese one has a
couple of alternative games on there
like it doesn't come with Final Fantasy
6 but it has like the mystical ends of
mystical ninja Konami side-scrolling
kind of wacky co-op action game I'm also
excited that the chords are what double
the length of my have to sit as close to
the TV
it's so weird yeah why what is what is
the reasoning behind that is there any
good reason makes a lot of sense for a
Japanese perspective because that your
living space is really small sorry are
we Japanese you guys
[Music]
Wow yeah no no but but I think to Mike's
point like it's this is a global
probably yeah I mean obviously they
shouldn't just consider that but like
yeah you know I've well sistent Lee
considered all of this I love to imagine
the meeting where we're like what if we
make everything mini and then someone's
like what about the chords are like same
there do it mini chords like that will
ferrell S&L bit with the phone Chloe no
it's Stella mm-hmm she's on her way
there you have it I I wanted to drop to
Gabe's one cool spot you made that up
no not yeah I mean I played a lot of
that game it's bizarre as like it's
weird seven up cool spot it's weird it's
a logo wearing sunglasses running around
the beach oh my god wait you were not
kidding oh okay well I played wait am i
randomly included we played a lot of
this game it's just that what is he
using tracks he's cool spot he's the
seven upload he's a pepperoni we're in
sunglass he looks like those the
California raisin cap from that game
that they released weirdly from
marketing back in a day oh you'd
remember the annoyed video game no you
don't even know the noise are do you
know damn it you're annoyed no avoided
yeah you did avoid the noise you managed
to you want to know this is a curveball
and I'm Jon we can pull it up the I try
playing I got my sister actually what
the head look goes portable yeah I seen
its necesitas and because we have all
our it's all games so she was able to
play and she didn't even use it so I
took it from her but her second game
Wayne's World like randomly like my
sister was obsessed with but I try
playing another day it's so bad yeah
does it have like digitized voices yeah
beginning when you press Start so bad
they really captured Michael Myers it's
like when you die when you die it's like
yeah it's like the guy Noah's arcade
made this game you know
it's cool it's hip yeah it's Noah's
arcade actually one more last one is the
Jurassic Park its nest game super as
well play those hard
Zombies Ate My Neighbors if you put that
on there I'll pay $300 for this thing
well it's the best game ever made I do
have some questions on Twitter from a
few people
first off Samuel Davis was saying are
any of us fans of the Mega Man X mhm I
love Mega Man X the first one at least
I've never played anything past that but
I love that game the first through the
fourth are pretty solid
after that they get kind of garish and
repetitive you should see the design
like how Mega Man X like the amount of
armor you can get added on to himself
like once you start getting into X 5 and
6 it just gets kind of out there yeah 1
through 4 really good one is just so
tightly designed it's it's great it's
also one of my favorite soundtracks the
Boomer Kwang err soundtrack I just like
it yeah it's really good
this game is uh I mean all the like Mega
Man 2 and the first one are insanely
hard games to me but Mega Man X it it's
not as hard as those games but I still
found it hard and I returned to it kind
of recently my brother still plays to
read in tendo games kind of religiously
and I was playing this and Zombies Ate
My Neighbor plural and I suck at Mega
Man games now mmm they're tough I mean
it's a different pace it's a different
style of like action we don't really
don't really make games like this yeah
that we play on a regular basis anyway
how do you mean by that um if it's hard
to describe no it's not hard to describe
it's like this is a pretty simple game
like on its face right and the
challenges in front of you aren't that
difficult to understand it really just
comes down to performing with these like
really tight your perfection and twitchy
controls it can be a little bit twitchy
yeah and enemies are good as sort of
distracting you and throwing you off but
like you should just be able to just
like stop for a second look at what
you're doing assess it and tackle it but
I think we're so used to in games now
being able to kind of charge ahead and
make up for you know any mistakes we
make it's rare that you see a game that
like
has pitfalls these days right where you
died from falling in a pit like
something like that yeah it's just it's
just unusual so you kind of have to like
retrain your brain when you're going
back to play a lot of these games right
I do have another question I want to get
to kind of a two-parter Errol Moss who's
in our twitch chat a lot and I was at
our e3 show do you think there will be
an n64 classic eh we'll get to that and
do you think these classic systems are
may be what's holding back a Nintendo
from bringing a switch Virtual Console
to life I don't think there will be a
Nintendo 64 :
I'm probably wrong but when I look at
the library of games there's not that
many that really stand out is like oh
wow like I think maybe we could all
count like 5 and 10 to 64 games that we
really love and then if you look at
those games now as well like there it's
kind of crude 3d it doesn't have the
charm of like surely pixel art Goldeneye
is so hard to come back it did not know
yeah so and if you sort of put that up
against you know these other games that
are that that looked great and play
really well I just don't think that that
really aligns with what Nintendo's doing
because I think maybe people haven't
played in 10 to 64 lately but we but we
see all these like you know we see
Megaman X on like iPhones or you know II
mean like stuff like that so we're we
still thinking about this stuff but we
don't win the last time yeah you really
looked at Goldeneye mm-hmm and like
played it like yeah it's it's that yeah
the idea of just nostalgia taking over
and like yeah going back to Goldeneye I
literally like the last time we did I
think we was a couple years ago we
played it on was the but that let's play
we had the show why that Chris Watters
did anyway it was like four of us
replacement six before games on the
extra life flashes well called
couch I don't know anyways we just had
the hardest time playing that game like
you're squinting yellow and like the TV
is kind of far away like you can barely
see people it's just and you're strafing
around it's just it's not a great Q
match one one quick fingers before Italy
yeah Filipe ITAR and twitch was seeing a
lot of the good n64 games were made by
rare and now Microsoft how hard would
that be get those on something like that
for Nintendo that's exactly what was
gonna say
well I don't know cuz minecraft is owned
by Microsoft and that's on every
platform one in this right maybe that's
a special case I was gonna see there's
there's literally one n64 game that I
replay consistently it's banjo kazooie
and I it's on Xbox there's a better game
than that that you could be replaying no
I'm not gonna get into this with you and
Joey
Cathy plaguey mrs. plaguey if you're
watching banjo tooie is better than
banjo kazooie I'll I'll debate you on
this show you're my mom well with with
words well yeah
yah banjos who is better on the 20th of
every month I tweet about it just to let
everybody know but yeah it's I would be
interested to see how like banjo tooie
is better than banjo kazooie Cathy
plaguey come at me
primetime HBO get your friends to come
watch it Cathy plaguey I'm calling you
out get on this show come up to San
Francisco I'll debate you I've got a
whole argument ready ready to go for you
mrs. plaguey
okay thank you yeah and then I'd also be
interested leaving I just I want I would
love to play all these games on the
switch the Super Nintendo games right
not n64 cuz I mean n64 being the first
foray into 3d games like ocarina Super
Mario 64 so important gonna mess look at
all those games we have better versions
of those games that are 3d and look
great we have Mario Galaxy we have any
number of more modern axalta games yeah
but you know Mario Kart Smash Brothers
things like that right like antennas
been evolving these series over the
years we still have access to those like
the Zelda's are on 3ds yeah 16-bit
animation or 16-bit like art style has
aged so I was more elegantly than the
early 3d Castlevania 64 that games bad
for a lot of reasons but I don't know I
still yeah I could play ocarina on 3ds i
cant play Majora's Mask on 3ds you know
she'll buying a 3ds I don't know I I
honestly could do with Ocarina of Time
Mario 64 and that's it right I almost I
that's one getting
I would I mean depending on how much it
is I could see myself buying that dude
those games still hold up so well
mario64 is so fun ocarina I've I've been
like five times I've gone back to that's
the one reason I pull out a 64 is for
those two Conker's Bad Fur Day guru riot
mentioned you guys play that not in love
with it I never played it is this super
mature despite the fact that he's a
mature is squirrel fox immature raccoon
what is he what does conquer a squirrel
he's a squirrel yeah I got it right the
first time I went through a few more
animals BAE yeah I'm heterosphere that's
one it's all about mischief-makers right
micromachines
n64 oh my god best party game ever
Pokemon Stadium you brought up a good
point but my stadium - [ __ ] of like
going back Iman snaps but we went back
to Rogue Squadron member that yeah and
it was like oh yeah this is different
yes it's it's interesting how some doing
some don't Aramis thank you so much for
your question as always we appreciate
you taking part in the show uh any last
thoughts on Super Nintendo games
Nintendo in general beats got one more
thought no I don't okay I'm cool I also
want to talk about you know we know
what's coming out the holiday season now
after e3
tober is pretty busy month month
November's got a couple releases
September got destiny - what else we
have in September we got a few things
but I want to talk about the games
remaining this summer before the holiday
season hits and what you should look
forward to what we're looking forward to
I'm just gonna rattle through them
splatoon - on the switch July 21st well
sorry I mean I guess you could start
with crash insane trilogy you could
we're not talking about it yet in terms
of review that'll be out soon --is-- but
you've been playing it mm-hmm
yeah mm-hmm yep when will that review be
up can you talk about it tomorrow
some was asking in the chat crash insane
trilogy from Naughty Dog who it wasn't
naughty dog that actually remastered it
wasn't Vicarious Visions
what else have they done I forget okay
I'm gonna play the game vicariously
through you because I don't wait wait
but anyways splatoon July 21st yeah me
too sorry I never played splatoon in the
first one I'm looking forward to playing
a splatoon game because I played a
switch far more often than I ever played
the Wii U what is that doing different
it seems like it's just you know like a
lot of people just iterating on the
first game but you know like I asked
someone like what's different about it
they're like oh you could do a wheel now
like halo 2 halo yes yes there was a
good new co-op mode salmon run we have
gameplay of it from e3 oh right well
good timing
Oh nicely done John sounds gross umm it
does theirs they really hit like the
fish imagery really hard and this in
these games right cuz they're a lot like
a lot of Myr they're humans but isn't
aren't there octopi involved wait so
it's like it's basically splatoon is
like post-apocalyptic and humans have
evolved to be squids sort of that's what
in simplest explanation come of it
hyper fashionable squids yeah they are
very fashionable I love getting new
clothes in this game the music is great
in this game too right yeah I like the
music if you want a preview of that
there's a splatoon mode and Mario Kart 8
deluxe so you can check out the map and
it has this Latino music um yeah I like
it it's such a unique take on a shooter
I I think I've said this on this show
before but I really need there to be a
little more communication because there
is strategy involved I mean there's like
classes you can be a heavy you can be a
sniper like it it it goes pretty deep
which and that was not in the first game
no no no that was in the first game but
what I would want to see from this one
different would be would be that sure
well you can plug your headset into your
phone one is obstinate no online service
to voice chat with your team's because
normal now you can use mixer oh the
other big difference is the inkling girl
has short hair now nice huh
that's I'm in here do you review this
yes I did Robert I already reviewed
what's uh what did was there a lack of a
single player or something no no there
was a thing
Claire moans I can't remember if there
was something that you like I remember
you mentioning something about like it's
hard to come back to it or something I
don't know like yeah I mean the
singleplayer it does a good job of sort
of escalating like the challenges so you
it's a really good way to just kind of
get to know the controls and different
weapons but once you've gone through it
that's kind of it like yeah there are
sort of alternative you know objectives
like you know finding hidden stuff if I
remember correctly but but yeah I mean
the single player was really just a very
good long winded tutorial in my mind can
we talk about how that that dialogue pop
up said raspy voice something about Papa
and eggs yeah that's a little creepy
typical conversation Monday's a weird
life yeah but yeah so splatoon too for
the new tennis which July 21st
what about pyre the third game from
supergiant games who also made Bastion
and trans sister Greg Kasavin
from of former GameSpot fame has been
working at Super Johnny for a while now
this game is really fun I played it last
year at some point and the weird take on
football but also there are these RPG
overworld fantasy elements that play
into it you're upgrading different
characters as you go in terms of like
out it's a weird genre blend of this you
know like fantasy RPG like I just said
and sports game but the actual sport
they've created is really fun
you can - then you get like actual you
have to bring this ball to this portal
at the end and the other person's like
end zone so to speak but there's a lot
more nuance to it and I really can't
wait to play this game it seems like
it'll be a good palate cleanser after
everything else I've been playing is so
you know it seems so original and also
just the writing is very you know
supergiant ish if you play transistor or
Bastion and I'm looking forward to that
a lot actually
I know Michael hi I'm was pretty excited
for that too after he just played it
recently I think did you guys play
transistor and everything mr. transistor
I think my favorite part of that game
was the music I loved the music and that
game yeah I'm looking forward to fire
that is July 25th a few days after
splatoon - from Fulbright company Tacoma
it's the second game C not sequel sorry
the second game sophomore effort from
Hobart company who made gone home Tacoma
be out August 2nd they show that off of
the Microsoft press conference
that'll be launching first on Xbox one
it's a console launch exclusive it's a
Xbox one and PC and then it'll be on a
Playstation and I would assume like
steam and whatnot mmm
but yeah Space Station very
narrative-driven kind of gone home
except instead of finding notes and
whatnot you're finding these Holograms
of people it's actually we have a little
more coming out about the fulbright
company in a couple weeks but we I got
the chance to actually play through a
little more of it recently and it's
really cool how you can actually
fast-forward and rewind these augmented
reality hologram scenes it's not just
this static thing you can actually
control so I'll be like Minority Report
kind of yeah kind of yeah exactly it's
it's you'll be in this kitchen and
everybody will be convening for this
this holiday that they created to stay
sane in space and then but if you rewind
it you can go back to the rooms they're
in before that and kind of talking [ __ ]
about other people or talking like doing
this transmission to earth or whatever
it is and then you go in and then you
kind of have different context for this
group scene afterward it's really cool
and then also just in terms of like
unlocking doors and whatnot you can you
can go through you rewind this scene and
then you hear her or input her code so
you can get into her office later on
after that scene on plays it's really
cool I'm looking forward to this a lot
and it seems like they're doing a lot to
change that you know the the derogatory
term now being walking simulator it
seems like they're doing a lot to change
up what gone home did and I'm excited to
see how that unfolds here I think this
is two more I honestly from our UK
office he'd spent a lot of time throwing
stuff in that toilet I could be wrong in
Toulouse but he also he also spent a lot
time turning into toilet paper and pray
so it's kind of right and Psyche
on-brand for him yeah it's it's like the
somebody made a joke that it was like a
pray without a gun great the disclaimers
footage looks much yeah there's
something this framerate is not great
yeah don't take this footage you know
count this game looks really good from
what I played yeah it does I I just
really like the I mean they did this
with gone home to like going through an
environment and picking up stories that
you want to find um I'm just really
really excited to get that in a
different context
yeah and
I don't know there's something really
special about being able to explore
freely and and get you know wonder what
happened to these people and I do like
like rewinding an event and hearing
people talking [ __ ] or like hearing
about like a couple comforting each
other
sure like listening to you know your
your typical like audio log trope of
just like having someone you know spit
out a monologue can get kind of boring
after a while but like what was the one
mission in mission but like the one
video recording and pray we if it just
seems like a generic to scientists like
having like it's in dialogue but if you
like if you've walked around you could
see that he actually went and like
revealed a safe or something like that
the glass or something looking glass yes
well the looking glass is the actual
assistant that used to like this video
system they use but ya know you I
thought it was broken first if you use
this console taking this
I don't spoil it yeah I thought
something was broken but later on I
found out that yeah I was like actually
a way to get into a secret party I was
super cool yeah there are elements of
pray here both games you know kind of
inspired by that Looking Glass legacy of
System Shock is like Steve Gaynor used
to be big fan of those games he has zero
4-5-1 tattooed on his arm really just
kind of a number that keeps showing up
in a lot of those games that came from
origin systems Looking Glass inspiration
lawbreakers August 8th jean-luc was just
playing this there's eight character
classes now as opposed to the three or
four there were when I last played it
I'm actually gonna play this game it's
really fun it's much more people are
comparing to overwatch but outside of
the character classes and the
multiplayer shooter aspects it's super
different it's much faster paced it's
more of like a I don't know this is kind
of reductive if you combine overwatch
and maybe like a quake or Unreal
Tournament that's what you would kind of
get obviously Cliff Bleszinski worked on
on the Unreal it escaped me right now
but this game is fun it's it's
fast-paced I'm probably gonna play it on
PC although Jake Decker played it on ps4
and said it's still really fun it's
obviously a little slower paced as is
the case with most PC shooters that make
their way to consoles I'm looking
forward to this more than I thought up
but you know the closer I get to it it
just seems you know while I'm waiting
for quake champions from Bethesda just
you know like who knows when that's
gonna come out yet I
does that have a release date quake
champions I don't think they announced
at e3 yet today I just kind of left beta
recently lawbreakers though I don't know
Rob are you okay are you interested in
this at all sorry I'm screwed here Rob I
wasn't for a really long time and then I
I saw it
you know this more recent gameplay and
I'm really excited this is absolutely
100% my [ __ ] like I want to I love like
a fast-paced a lot of vertical movement
shooter um so I'm really looking forward
to actually checking this out robbery by
you sorry yeah no you're good I played
it like a year ago yeah you mentioned
like yeah there's definitely like four
classes but I'm just looking at this
footage now yeah I'm definitely more
intrigued I think it looks like they've
like implemented a lot more like
mobility like sliding and surroundings
like that like you know I love time fall
for that very reason like I like that
fast-paced like parkour aspect and those
like those well they like zero-g areas
that seems like a cool change of pace
yeah which is I remember before this is
weird comparison but remember when we
first are showing of Call of Duty
infinite warfare we were hoping they
would use the zero-g on the multiplayer
maps and then it turned out to be in my
opinion pretty boring multiplayer but
this is kind of what they I wanted was
the CRT because a lot of character class
is uh one that only was using earlier
get to someone with a chain gun
apologies for not knowing these names
but they actually just have a jet like
divas movement kind of overwatch you
just actually jet through the
environment and that leads to some
interesting than the grappling hook a
lot of these movement tropes they're
become kind of standard multiplayer
shooters lately but it seems like law
breakers mechanically is pulling them
off really well especially considering
some parts of these maps are zero-g and
I'm really excited because I've never
even seen this class before this class
is new to me but back when I played it I
forget what it was you know like six
months ago
it was just like three or four character
classes and I thought that was gonna be
it but now yeah they're eight I'm
looking forward to us when this is come
out again August 8 not crazy far away
but again before you know summer hits
the same day a game that I am career
kind of curious about a hell-blade Pete
I think you and I talked to us a few
times it kind of has like heavenly sword
ish vibes maybe or no mm that a good
comparison well it has a female
maybe resembles the female in that game
oh that's not what I was saying or join
for I don't know like I was actually I
thought it reminded me of a combat of
heavenly sword with narco we seen a lot
of combat for helping ya lever like a
game for me to cover story from what I
read it sounded like it anyway no I
thought it was a game I thought it was
most of it mostly a narrative driven
game about the trials of mental illness
yeah that's a metaphor below all this
like gothic fantasy stuff it seems like
but I don't know are you excited for
this game it all say that I'm curious
about it yeah and I'm curious because
they said it's gonna be a short game and
they're only charging I think 30 or 40
dollars for talk I'm thinking of
something completely different sorry I
think so maybe so yes I am very
interested yeah do you guys know much
about it and play more than I do
no cool untried The Lost Legacy August
22nd standalone DLC sorry not even DLC
just standalone game from Naughty Dog is
featuring Chloe Frazier and Nadine Ross
Nadine rosters introducing untried for
Chloe from uncharted 2 but this goes
back into their backstories a little bit
and their relationship before we see
them apparently you know uncharted 2 & 4
I'm excite for this they showed a little
more off of how Nadine is gonna or how
you're yeah because you're playing Chloe
but how Nadine is actually gonna factor
into the combat and you know its
movement it looks really cool when you
go to attack someone she comes up as a I
like uncharted 4 had this really well
but just seems to be to focus more on
these two characters but when you're
actually attacking someone she'll come
up and finish them off for you and vice
versa Nadine was a great character yeah
for right yeah she's pretty badass she
kicked the [ __ ] out of Nathan Drake in
one part uh her just so her like in the
end just like I'm out her plot thread
kind of didn't tie off as well as I
liked it to something interesting to see
what will happen in this obviously this
is before everything but I'm looking
forward to seeing what they do with this
it looks gorgeous but I I really like
most things naughty dog does something
exciting for this kind of reminds me of
it's like those the old blood and then I
dishonored to doing death the outsider
that standalone experiences that I'm you
know it's it's it's not just DLC it's
actually you don't have to play on try
before I don't believe to play this
which is weird but this is also like a
prequel so I think it'll do well in
terms of like maybe introducing people
to the series or actually bring
people in 204 who knows that's August
22nd mario + rabbits kingdom battle yeah
yeah yeah August 29th same day as X come
to war of the chosen DLC X our expansion
major expansion but obviously those
funny they're coming out the same day
because I remember Jake selling the XCOM
creator was saying he's watching Ubisoft
conference and saw this is like what is
happening much more in-depth than it
originally looked I think the you know
the Nintendo Ubisoft car Rabbids
cartoonish graphics kind of Balai how
much depth there actually is yeah I can
move into this seems super interesting
it's so weird that like these Rabbids
and everybody have these weird guns and
grenades and whatnot but yeah as someone
who is enjoying playing like actually
having a reason a lot of reasons to play
on a Nintendo console and m'as XCOM I
can't wait for this I'm so intrigued by
this game it's so bizarre I feel like if
anything the only thing I'm gonna like
if I stop playing this game it'll be
because the Rabbids irritate me mm-hmm
um but I I love that they're doing
something like totally out there and I
like that like this is the kind of game
that I would have been more likely to
pick up as like a like a younger you
know a kid or a young teen over
something like ex-cons because it's you
know less it's more accessible yeah
right and so I like that you know it's a
different genre with a more accessible
feel yeah but it actually looks like it
could be you know decently challenging
to I'm worried about what's gonna happen
to my state of mind on this day because
X come to expansion comes out which I'll
play before I play this honestly but um
so no secret I love XCOM 2 and the
expansion looks like it's changing up a
lot of things they took of some
inspiration we interviewed the X element
on our lobby stage actually at e3 if you
haven't caught it it was a fun interview
they're taking these three kind of
Nemesis system from shadow of Mordor he
said they took inspiration from that in
terms of how these bosses are gonna
start reacting to you and playing
differently and kind of you're having
these personal beefs with them as
opposed to these you know static
characters and the series past static
enemies in this series past but also
there's three new character classes they
look on Rio I'm really excited for this
some kind of saying in terms of a how
big this is it's bigger than the enemy
within which is the major expansion for
enemy unknown mmm what were you saying
Rep actually nothing important doesn't
say that last dude looked like I'm at
work yeah yeah I would say so
if you haven't played ex-con to complain
now that's the reaper class they look on
real like glass can in stealth character
I can't wait
anyway but cool any other games no I
don't think so I think I got them all
this summer mm-hmm so I review for Crash
Bandicoot crash insane trilogy will be
up tomorrow tomorrow hey what time
embargo is 7 a.m. I think ok cool yeah
what are you guys doing mr. sweet Kelly
what are you playing anything
I'm trying to still haven't beaten Zelda
so I want to beat it before the DLC drop
so farming to upgrade my armor because
I'm a loser that's what I'm doing with
amiibo like Nick margarita and no no
I've been like hurry now I've been for
who firming dragon first oh nice oh yeah
where'd you get that guide this guy yeah
Jesus held on Friday Rob oh my god I am
I have it all I've been uh I've been
upgrading my Hummer as well and yeah
these damn amiibos in this office
driving me insane
yeah Nick got like a bunch of the really
rare items on his first and second tries
of certain amiibo he didn't reload saves
and to be fair he tried for like several
weeks to get that one shield from toon
Zelda so I feel like he earned this luck
a little bit uh do you guys have a Dino
DNA stream this week oh that old show we
used to do you don't do Dino DNA anymore
I don't know what happened to that show
we might are you streaming Thursday we
might have something else in the works
okay we're gonna stream Friday we're
gonna play Zelda cool play for a few
hours nice maybe all day
we are you gonna do the like hard mode
yeah we're gonna try to we do it all
we're gonna like see if we can do the
trials of the sword it'll take a while
to get there it's hard mode right to get
to the the forest grotto or whatever
it's called well I don't think we're
gonna try to get to the trials in hard
mode I think we might yeah take a
current save and
been the hardest to suit it's like cool
yeah we're um that should be fun
before I just seen that I've also been
playing titanfall yeah new DLC yesterday
love that game I I really like this new
map it's like it's just it's so
rewarding to fly around that war games
war games from the first game I actually
never played it was part of the
expansion for titanfall I never actually
played a lot of those maps so it's cool
to hear the praise about these maps yeah
war games apparently is one of the
better ones as far as parkouring goes oh
yeah here's hot gameplay and this new
execution won't encourage him jean-luc
thank you for
riling him up right at the end of the
show yeah no it's it's a cool execution
for those don't get it if you have
titanfall it's time to come back we've
been waiting it's it's free it's time
titanfall to come back it's not free
come out as DLC is free don't listen to
rob I'm the only ball look at this
alright okay I'm calling it yeah
technical fault Evo seems out now
necromancer is out for Diablo 3 erekt a
data stream yesterday it's archived on
YouTube twitch grunting or on youtube if
you wanna go check that out but anyway
yeah that's our show next week
got a pretty light week in terms of
releases again insane trilogy if you're
not interested in that then it's crashed
one through three with new graphics
that's all you need to know awesome
thank you so much
Jeremy's all Errol moss and Samuel Davis
for your questions through Twitter John
Luke Erte thank you in the back for a
producing the show Richard Lee is out
for the rest of the week
but we will be back next week here in
the US we have Monday Tuesday off for
4th of July Independence Day weekend but
we'll be back Wednesday and thanks for
stopping by we'll see you then
[Music]